[Music]
all Noel wanted for Christmas was the
perfect life she'd always planned on I
thought we could be one big happy family
you know I'm allergic you are gonna be
such a good dad but when her new puppy
made a mess of everything my autographed
baseball by important Carribean sofa all
busted maybe we could call him buster
I can't do this she found herself left
out in the cold our adventure columnist
I know this is gonna sound strange but
why do you come with me we've got plenty
room at the farm so when is Jessica
coming up I can't wait to meet her we
have heard so much about you this is not
Jessica this is Noel from work hi now
with a little training shoulder that the
best gets in life I have no boyfriend no
home and soon no job are the surprises
you never see coming
how's the hunky cowboy she's great
really really great Jessica's not coming
I broke it off trying to share this with
her I'm not gonna share with him mothers
too entertainment presents
Cindy Busby Greyston halt
Christopher Russell Alison price and
Victoria's snow in a romantic Yuletide
story about how the key to finding true
love is first being true to yourself
there is no perfect key to a
relationship it doesn't have to be
perfect it just has to be true a puppy
from Christmas
you
you